as the debate intensifies about how long
to continue the coronavirus locked down
in this country we want to bring in one
of the nation's top experts on
infectious disease epidemics joining us
from Baltimore dr. Thomas Inglesby
director of the center for health
security at Johns Hopkins University dr.
let's start with the astonishing spread
of this virus one week ago we had 25,000
cases and 307 deaths but as of Saturday
we had 121 thousand cases and 2 thousand
deaths what does that tell you about the
nature of this virus and where are we in
its course it's spread here in the
United States well it tells us that this
virus is able to spread pretty
efficiently and quickly we've seen that
around the world in the last few months
and we should expect that to keep
happening in the United States I think
unfortunately we are still at the very
beginning of this outbreak and we should
you expect that to continue for some
time and really focus on social
distancing as one of our main
interventions of trying to slow it I'm
gonna pick up on that because I want to
ask you about president Trump's evolving
policy on how to handle the virus as you
know his initial 15 days to stop the
spread of the virus guidelines run out
tomorrow the 15 days end tomorrow and he
is now talking about the possibility in
certain what he calls low-risk parts of
the country where there's a low
incidence of the virus reopening those
areas by Easter here he is this week
there are large sections of country
probably can go back much sooner than
other sections
will that work and what about the
president's discussing the idea that you
could have some areas of the country
where you could begin to open in two
weeks yeah at this point we're seeing
numbers go up around the country pretty
consistently there isn't really any
place in the country where we've seen
numbers go down and we wouldn't expect
to have had enough time for social
distancing to change the numbers so I
don't think we have had nearly enough
time for these measures to take to take
full effect I do think in the future
it's possible that parts of the country
once they get control of this virus that
maybe states or regions could begin to
relax social distancing measures a
little sooner than other parts of the
country but as long as the numbers
continue to go up as they are around the
country I think we really need to hold
steady with the social distancing until
we have a number of different conditions
in place but I want to put up a map
because if you look at the situation
there are broad parts of the country
where you can see in the Northeast and
the New York general area some cities
big cities in the Midwest and on the
west coast where there are serious
hotspots and then there are broad areas
where there are very few cases so so why
can't we as the president is suggesting
treat different parts of the country
where the viruses at a very different
state treat those different parts of the
country differently well I think the
first reason is that I don't really have
confidence I don't think many in public
health have confidence that we really
know where all the cases are we've begun
to do much more diagnostic testing
around the country especially in places
where there is a lot of illness but in
some parts of the country we don't have
enough coverage of diagnostic testing
we're seeing what we see but there could
be twice as many three times as many
four times as many cases in a particular
area of the country that aren't yet
recognized so we need to get to a point
in the country where we have such
extensive diagnostic testing that we can
test people who have mild symptoms right
now
many in many places in the country if
you have mild symptoms you can't get a
test but those people can spread the
disease just as well as the people who
are sick in the hospital so we need to
get to a point where we have oh go ahead
no I I didn't mean to interrupt but the
president talks about in these certain
areas of the country that people could
actually go back to work go back to
offices as long as they practice the the
guidelines for these last 15 days in the
office social distancing in the office
good hygiene washing your hands a lot
take a look at what the president said
we could socially distance ourselves and
go to work and you have to work a little
bit harder you can clean your hands five
times more than you used to dr. Inglesby
will that work I don't think so
I think if we've seen in Italy for
example which is a number of weeks ahead
of the United States in terms of its
epidemic that even with very serious
very aggressive social distancing
measures where people have been kept at
home schools have been closed everyone
is is recommended not to leave their
homes that this disease has continued to
spread and it's causing national crisis
so at this point I think what we need to
do is really stick with what other
countries that have had more success
have done which is they've largely been
in Asia Singapore Hong Kong South Korea
China Taiwan they have put in place
social distancing measures until they've
gotten control of the epidemic
convincingly and at that point begun to
try experiments with loosening it and I
do think we will get to that point
obviously we need to as a country get to
a point where people can go back to work
but if we go back to work too quickly
this epidemic is going to spread widely
and aggressively and we won't have a
normal economy in that case anyway so I
really do think that you know while this
epidemic continues to be on the rise in
many places in the country and we don't
know enough about Diagnostics in many
other parts of the country we really
should hold the course
so if Easter as the president has
suggested is too soon to begin to loosen
the reins in the quote low risk areas
when would you say does the kind of
question reporters asking I'm sure
epidemiologists like you hate two
questions one what is the earliest that
you think that we could begin to lose in
the reins in some of the less affected
areas and then the question I'm sure
you're getting over and over how long is
this going to last
before we really go back to normal so I
think dates are hard to predict because
every day the numbers continue to go up
in many parts of the country I think we
should really have this more like a
conditions-based decision so when we see
a state or a region have numbers that go
down over time and when we have
diagnostics in place and when we have
masks available for all of our doctors
and nurses who are putting their lives
at risk to take care of you take care of
sick patients and hospitals are well
prepared and when we can get our public
health systems in place to start tracing
or identifying individuals and tracing
their contacts again like they do in
Asia I think those five major conditions
then I think it's a time to begin to
think about how we might experiment with
lightening social distancing perhaps one
step at a time
it's not clear to me when that's going
to happen I think we'll have to see
where we are in two more weeks in other
in other countries where they put social
distancing measures in place
aggressively it's taken about four weeks
for those measures to begin to have an
effect but at that point I think we
could begin to look for the conditions
that might make it safe to begin to
lower our social distancing but not
until then dr. Inglesby thank you thanks
for providing your expert analysis and
please come back sir